il s'est passé tant de choses depuis
notre dernière rencontre j'ai perdu mon
marteau
hier c'est tout récent je suis encore un
peu énervé ensuite je suis parti en
quête de moi même
et c'est toi que j'ai trouvé
ou est ce qu'on est si tu savais hélas
la déesse de la mort en eau veillaient à
ce gars là j'attendais ça depuis si
longtemps
tu sais on s'est battu l'autre jour et
j'ai gagné
non je gagnais facile tu es sûr de toi
t'as perdu
c'est tout
as garde est morte
et elle remettra bientôt à mon niveau
vous n'êtes donc pas contents de me voir
il nous faut l'arrêter au plus vite pour
empêcher le raid maroc la fin de toute
chose
donc je met sur pied une équipe
comme au bon vieux temps
surprise on va bien s'amuser
[Musique]
salut
vrai guerrier
je suis une vraie
je suis la déesse de la mort
et toi de quoi était le dieu au juste
on se ressemble tous les mois deux têtes
brûlées qui agissent sans réfléchir oui
on est les mêmes hulk comme le feu et
d'organes ou non je dirais qu'on est
tous les deux comme le feu et le quai
comme le feu en furie et or comme des
petites breizh